hey guys hi I hear one of you playing
back a
little I hear myself playing back
through your speakers no you don't I do
okay now I don't yeah I had my volume up
really high so oh okay sorry continue I
was done what
um
yeah all right here we go all I know is
that I've seen clips of this game are
very funny looking what even the
are we doing what is so about what do
you mean game this is our job yeah
welcome I mean hey fellow employees
where are we and also what is a profit
quota and why is the deadline 3 days
well we work for the company yeah the
company let's all sing the song we love
the
company the company the comp even if we
die we love
no one volunteers for this we are
here
oh the
company theany
[Music]
the all right that was a mandated
whoa
what the one dance the one dance oh yeah
oh snap yeah you got it you got it we
love the company oh yeah we love the
company hey love the company you love
the company I love the
comp hey so we need to go reach the
company's quota okay where so do we have
to leave
there this computer will allow us to
choose where we go we're already set to
go there so um whoever Bob I think you
have to pull the lever to start us off
oh okay all right our timer is started
uhhuh population abandoned hazard level
B as in very good H all right no I mean
the timer is literally started there is
a timer okay there's a timer I don't see
it where's the timer we it's over there
top middle of the screen the time it's
the time of day
it's up there whoa look at that you
pointed right at it that's really funny
check that out it's not really a timer
it's more well it is because we only
have until midnight no look there's a
red dot in the sky this this planet's
got an Acog scope oh snap hey yeah hey
that's the company looking out for us
somebody's firing a laser poter usace
the compy the company hey the
company what was that did you see that
what no is it's a
bird oh yeah you scan it right oh yeah
right click was your best friend you
scan things
whoa this is
cool and they're to a be I'm climbing a
ladder yeah what
whoa hey guys there's a ladder there's
nothing up here though there a good view
and good friend oh there's a there's a
silo over that way right if you right
click do you see anything appearing that
direction main entrance is that way the
hell over there over there that where we
go oh yeah that's it so we need to go to
main entrance we to go there oh my God
Mark are you okay ah bugs no bugs it's
bugs bugs bugs everywhere yep if you
like bugs you're going to love this game
cuz it has oh bugs that we just I I seem
to be getting tired the more I run I
don't like
that we do you have stamina from the
comp
stamina
okay uh main
[Music]
oh
what we love the
company the
company
I got
money uh I overran it there a it's over
here oh there it
is this is and now we scavenge for
the hi good progress hello oh
echoey we love the the
compy the radios or something not yet
what do you mean not yet we haven't we
don't have radios oh okay I just needed
Clarity yeah I'm going to open this door
that was a scary sounding door I'm going
to open this this is not a door so over
here Mark I'm going show you something
nah
n hey I found a a
key oh cool nice key this a thanks I was
going this key h no we got the key mark
do you think this dark hallway is where
we want to be all right if I scream and
die uh well
oh okay okay one of us one of us at a
time I the key the key hey there's a
light over there oh there's a light over
there I got
it
oh well I got it
oh increase levels of R okay that ignore
that that's that's fine probably fine oh
hey hey hey what's up oh hey you got a
key I got a key where a key guys look at
what Mark's got where'd you go got
increased levels of radiation oh yeah I
got radiation we love the company the
company am I done do I take this back I
I feel like it's the you can see how
many slots you have or how many things
you can carry so it's up to you my hands
are full I feel like I want to use you
can press G to drop it if you wanted to
mm take it back makes me there were
there were lights before you did what
you did this is a light your right click
is your best
friend tattered metal sheet oh I give me
give me that give me you need some light
I got a light yeah yeah thanks man
you're well not you oh what what did I
do I'm going this I'm going the same way
as W so okay well I'm following you and
not wait also uh that is heavy Mark
you'll notice you have some weight now
next to your little person so I'm very
strong I'm very strong oh tip use the
ship computer terminal to access secure
doors oh okay that is a thing you can do
I um okay hey storage room there's got
to be some in here how do I crank up the
light on this thing he can you can you
be a little light litier yeah if I shake
it oh see wait did you hear the sh sha
Shas anyone hear that yeah I think it
came from this
direction which way we should this this
way this way yeah this way go towards
the dancing man okay on the way what are
we looking for exactly anything pick up
a I mean I have that
wait wait who
wait what I don't know think I pissed
myself you just hear things yeah was
that did someone just take like a like a
deep breath oh what is going on
there uh I don't know I didn't see what
it was yeah it looks you go first Bud it
looks fine to me oh yeah you go first
Mark okay yeah Mark you got the light
nothing happened you
Goofs oh oh
hey that probably Weir I think it was
but how dare
you I'm already in the hole you hey
large
axle oh yeah baby nice whoa um you guys
hear that yeah I definitely heard
something there
yeah
uh-huh oh oh oh oh oh hey uh Bob he
dropped that for a second pick this up
first and pick it back
up
yes okay is there marker are
you cloud of gas now or I don't know
about that I think I shook this thing
and it's making more light oh never mind
found a ninja oh oh nice man well how
how many how many slots Are you full up
cuz I'm full full all full so we should
head back okay all right should we go
cash sh our goodies with the company
that we love yeah we love the
company I have an inate sense of
direction do you want to follow me yeah
please I don't remember where we are I
know where we
are the dead on I think he's definitely
leading us the right
way I have conf to
hear I love Mark almost as much as I
love the company thanks man that's all
I'm going to say um this isn't the way I
remember this doesn't feel as familiar
as I would the stone staircase really
seemed wrong never lead us astray yeah I
would never I yeah I was it's
locked hey
on
hey this is going to take us right back
guys this looks different yeah well we
we door open we' been here
yeah hey look servers and whatnot you
remember the servers oh yeah I remember
walking through here and being like Oh
look I wonder if those are Zeon Pro ah
yes this lovely server room that doesn't
lead anywhere uhoh uhoh got pilot chip
hey that means it's 10 p.m. and we're
out of time oh okay we should go then
don't worry I have a good sense of
direction I know where to go serum o
like a map or anything not that I don't
trust
Mark cuz I trust Mark with my life
there's no map in
here oh there is a map that looks very
not useful no it's fine wait do you do
you have any idea where Mark is taking
us and or where maybe Mark is no I got
it I got it this way guys this way this
way this way this way this way I got it
I got it I remember now yeah I took a I
took a
wrong wrong
soour uh uh-huh a little bit back but
but I remember where um okay I remember
where I oh
that that's weird oh neat oh um
uh uh doesn't look
good uh B jump
jump
uh
[Music]
w we lost bom uh out well I well you
mean I oh oh interesting
oh I didn't even have two seconds to
consider what I what I had did wrong
there before I was joined by my fellow
employes all right congratulations boys
we lost $36 and made zero okay cool
successful first day oh man that was a
good nap you guys remember anything from
yesterday no yesterday's a blur to me
this is my first day on the job as far
as I know well let me initiate you
there's a great song that we sing for
new
employees Company the company the
company the
company hey hey anyway um maybe you guys
go and I'll stay in the command center
don't have let me show you something Bob
we can go different places if you go
into this terminal and you type moons
you can pick a place for us to go uh
company building experimentation
Assurance bow offense March Ren dine
Titan the last three cost money to go to
so we probably can't afford it but you
can try
confirm excellent confirm what we're
going to offense oh hey Bob you want to
see mag magic trick what's that behind
your
ear oh it's a note it says I love you oh
uh actually it doesn't say
that um so boys I just spend the last of
our money what we had money on what we
had $24 I bought two walkie-talkies oh
two hey that's almost enough yeah if you
want to guide us here uh we can go where
I can or Mark you do it uh I mark would
you rather have me or Wade with you
that's the
question man who do you trust more being
the man in the chair guiding you
oh there's no wrong answer we will be
offended can I flip a a a lens cap
no no
no follow me follow me while we decide
you mean what's follow the ice cream
truck
oh our goodies we love the company we
love the company we love the company we
love the company oh boy the company love
the company compy now so what do it oh
my God it dropped these mark it drops
off the things I bought no it went in
the
sky look at our hand see how I have a
walkie and wait as a walkie our what
what do I do to where's
mine I'm just so excited you want that
one how do we how do we talk Q to turn
it on and then left
click by
the love the
compy who's
chairing CH what wait us yeah wait you
got
this uh you want the here you have the
you have that you talk to the I don't
want to talk to him we
love theany
hey what was
that yeah I hear you in real
life to right huh
Roger wait can you tell what's he saying
what's what's he saying he's saying he's
saying we need to go to the right ah so
you can't hear him when he
walkie-talkies no no but it's okay we're
going right what a mark seems to
be oh he found quick is dead
I think it's because you picked the
place that was
raining so you don't you don't want to
go in that is what you're saying no you
don't got it got it so I I'll show you
how to get into the facility it's a
different we're at a different Moon okay
uh
Mark we're so sorry you died he just he
just he just wanted he just wanted to go
in in there but that looks like
quick oh God yeah I know that look the
same looks like the same thing that
killed Mark yeah I just wanted to show
you what not to do oh okay quick Sand's
very easy to avoid if you're not me I
would normally go a different way but I
think we're have to do
this oh
good
ow I'm fine I'm fine we love the company
the
company
that well it's 2: p.m already so things
are going really well oh that looks like
quick standand again oh hey quick
standand okay well that's good practice
that's good practice man I picked a real
of a place to get into huh yeah
whenever the moons have conditions
they're always a bit risky oh okay
cool like I wasn't going to say that I
wanted you to you know live and
learn I I should shall we spread out
since we've got the walkies yeah that's
fine I I'll go to the right here hey
there's like a
thing a thing with like a laser on the
ground here is that
bad
wait
out
ah so I found a
turret
that was uh oh did you did you see that
um yeah I saw did you could you hear
what way screamed it be yeah yeah I I I
could hear about as well as you could
hear which is uh not soon enough I love
the
company the
company the company Mark we're really
good at this game I we're we're good
yeah we're getting our paychecks that's
for sure I mean I could go back and try
to
all of this but I really feel like I
both why is he talking to dead guys I
think he's just
talking yeah I'm just going to take off
now okay but why isn't he getting my
body you're you're we couldn't get your
body you disappeared into the quick you
didn't even try company I love the
company my CPR is going to work
eventually
Bob you're not going to die on me Bob
I'm pretty sure I'm already dead yeah
stay
alive mark it says that you are the
laziest employee I don't know about that
hey a
good hey guys hey what's up guys hey
what's up guys how's it going all right
oh profit qu okay that's easy so you
recharge that Bob at the top left you
have a charging bar you recharge it
right
here oh oh my God it has it's the I wish
my phone charged like that how damn uh
mark do you want to pick our moon this
time
M
no all right fine how okay he you you do
it you do it you just type moons and
pick the one you like the sound of
moon uh there was no subject There Was
No Object apply to the action or your
word was typed incorrectly or does not
exist Moon
plural Moon's plural Moon's with an S
moons
plural that didn't work
I well I'm tell I I tell you it works if
it really does just move m o NS m o o NS
all you got to type ah there we go oh
buying at 77% what are we buying vow
that's the company we don't want to go
to them yet we have one day to get their
quota of which we've reached zero here
we go yeah yeah yeah all right where
where we going Mark uh some place called
vow vow okay okay
abandon
[Applause]
terrain supports aggressive life forms I
I think you guys should Venture forth
and I'll stay in the boat this time okay
oh we fly you want know a trick Bob if
you go over to this computer type view
space
Monitor and the word switch is a good
friend oh switch you got a switch in
there I'm not seeing an
entrance um I think it's this way I
don't remember how would you know uh I
looked at the map there's a map oh I
found
it oh oh cool hell yeah
hey
woo oh oh we are inside do you want to
talk to Bob you don't me to talk to B uh
you got it but let me know if there's
anything important o what is
this can you open your
radio radio's on you hear that b
uh that's Mark's mating
call all right here's the thing if
there's any danger I'll just ring this
thing okay
oh Bob said to tell
you I told him um so this is an a
separate yeah Mark discovered the fire
exit door which I hadn't told you about
to discover it naturally which we did
what do you mean discover naturally this
how you experience life you just go
through life and you find things not
everything has a guide yep um Bob if you
see yellow triangles like the one next
to me that's an item I can pick up there
was no reason to come over here um
up well that's ominous looking he sees
red
flashing where in front of
us up here to the right you said what is
what does that mean what is he what is
he saying
there's something red down this way to
the right is that bad Red's usually bad
red is usually bad Mark Dead red SS is
bad what's he saying he's saying go this
way there's something on the floor yeah
we see it phone there is something on
the floor okay I got a
phone what what
now
huh said he see something moving away
from us that's good or unless it's a
friend I got I'm I'm full up man I Got
No Room Mark's full up he wants to head
back and drop his stuff off I think I
didn't say that I didn't say
that uh did you do
that
huh okay there's a there's a red dot
pretty vague about these red dots
there's another Red Dot waiting around
the corner to the right of us is that a
bad thing oh mark look up it's waiting
on the ceiling oh what does that
mean what does that mean whoa oh that
that seems uh uh uh danger what do I do
uh we see a giant
doll bad
stuff yeah have a bottle head I'll try
to scan it for
you
uh ah it's a I know what this
is
ding ding uh wow this thing is not fun
up close oh boy wait wait wait wait wa
don't look away from it yeah I know that
I know where am I going guide me
oh uh what wait exit toward me where
what do you mean you where are you are
you oh right where you came from oh I
didn't see okay let's go
y are you looking at it huh no oh
God okay down here come on it's right
here don't be a worry
wart go all right let's exit all right
let's exit
oh that was close it's not falling us
right no they can't leave the facility
oh okay well that's awfully convenient
for us I also can't communicate with B
when I'm holding a two-handed object
like this that's okay it's okay he knows
we're
coming I'm I'm doing my what do you mean
new creature creature data oh
Locus proper they' been known to comust
flames God okay okay all right hey
what's up guys I was just reading about
coil heads oh
why do you okay woo where do I put my
stuff I just G to drop it like over here
I got a cookie
pan I got old telephone I got tea kettle
look at me dang that's some value right
there that's some value
yeah oo you guys want to go back in what
is what's the
sound I don't know after five only got
like 6 hours before the ship's going to
take off without us is that enough time
not really if I'm being honest not
really well it sounds like then we
should go back but you keep saying it
like we're we'll just make a decision
like no we should go in as if that would
be a smart thing to do but you're saying
getting more stuff is a smart thing to
do but running out of time means we all
die yeah I know that I'm running low on
time yeah I'm aware but why are you even
saying it's an option I'm making an
executive decision yeah we go why you
wait what are you just thinking
something what are you
oh what's that sound
I heard something that we don't want to
deal with so I'm glad we're leaving
we're going it's fine yeah we're going
we're not going to look at it you think
we're just like going to try to catch
some interesting things like
no I'm the laziest employee look at me
you never credit for being the man in
the chair okay well hey I got four
experience guys I got 11 did we do it
did it company day yeah we we love the
[Music]
company and we love theet the profit
quarter you can use the terminal to rot
the autopilot to the company
building oh company building are we at
the
uh the
company you guys want to grab some stuff
to sell oh we actually I thought it
would just be you know I thought they'd
come get well I I'll get my stuff then
where's my tea
kettle I grabbed it but here would have
your stuff no it's my can I can I have
one thing to sell yeah you can sell the
big thing that I brought that's fine oh
okay yeah you can sell
that so welcome to
company we're here
baby hey company we're
home not that oh no no Mark what are you
doing no no no company property now no I
know I don't know thank God actually I
don't what do you
mean don't tell you're walking I'm not
I'm not I'm not mark my God guys don't
don't let that compan oh it is whoa did
I just see what the hell was that the
company we
lovey
the airor was very expensive Mark damn
it what is
whoa uhhuh okay that's cool that's
cool they may not like you ringing their
Bell
constantly well they got my air horn
so oh
boy I can I can tell when Wade's doing a
thing that's like you guys should not do
this dumb
[Music]
thing